hey guys it's me Debbie
the holidays are coming kids but if
there's one thing y'all should be
thankful for its having something like
me around to make sure that you don't
get fat so it's gonna be sheriff's on my
favorite holiday weight loss tips to get
you shredded before January and I'm
probably gonna suggest that you ignore
those tips don't you know that you've
gained 10 pounds during the holidays
grandmas pumpkin pie forget about it Oh
calm down Debbie
well a study found that most people
think they gain around three and a half
pounds in reality they usually gain just
under a pound in other words a mindful
slice of your grandma's favorite pumpkin
pie never heard anyway I know guy who
was diving pot so never say never sorry
to hear that Debbie but I really think
that in most okay guys so Thanksgiving
is around the corner we gotta get moving
let's get to January in a shoe string
bikini daddy we're Canadian I'm gonna be
over here in my snow pants in my parka
suit yourself
let's do this he liked the birds during
the day with no
big holiday meal hazards
Debbi that's a recipe for a binge when
you starve yourself all day physically
and psychologically you tend to arrive
at dinner so hungry you blast past your
dinner host in a frantic rage trying to
find a buttered dinner roll trust me any
calories you may have saved throughout
the day will be more than made up for it
in your hangry rampage instead I
recommend having breakfast lunch and
even a little snack before you go choose
to take the edge off so that way you can
make more healthy mindful decisions
about what to eat this party only serves
hors d'oeuvres so I believe in anything
you might be surprised research suggests
that when evidence of a meal is out of
sight so for example you don't see any
crumbs on your plate from that mini
quiche or the little tails from the
shrimp have been done away with it can
be really easy to overeat because you
kind of forget that you ate anything at
all so if you're planning to make a meal
out of snacks try to portion them all
out onto your plate at one time so that
way you can see yes this is a satisfying
amount of food for a meal rather than
kind of mindlessly noshing all night
long
I'm doing all my bacon bloom free this
year which is so much healthier than
regular bring on the gluten-free
pastries in cake no Debbie just know
I've said it before and I'm gonna say it
again unless you have celiac or are
gluten intolerant there is no reason to
be going out buying gluten-free pastries
thinking that they're a better choice
than their gluten filled counterparts
they're not plus a lot of gluten-free
products actually have more sugar and
fat in them because they have to make up
for the lack of texture and consistency
that gluten provides so enjoy your baked
goods this season gluten free or not
just don't go binging on them thinking
that gluten free equals calorie free
added me dinner so I'll have more
calories to drink tonight
bottoms up Oh Debbie this is a very
serious and slippery slope in my line of
work we tend to call this drunkorexia or
skipping meals so that you can binge
drink and not gain weight while alcohol
is calorie dense and drinking is common
practice during the holidays skipping
meals tends to backfire and may actually
be counterintuitive to your weight
management goals I mean when we drink so
much we get so loaded so fast that we
tend to lose our own decision-making
skills and we may make less healthy
decisions that went to eat don't believe
a word that Debbie says both her and I
have been in the same line for
late-night poutine
so instead make through the focus and
that cocktail or glass of wine kind of
the cherry on top and always make sure
to have at least two to three sips of
water after every sip of alcohol Oh
Adi what are you doing making this
holiday thing's way too easy
the holidays should be a time to
celebrate give thanks enjoy time at
family and friends and most importantly
find pleasure in food that doesn't mean
that it's a free-for-all and you've got
permission to go hog-wild but if you
slow down and you listen to your body
you'll likely find yourself satisfied
with the right amount of food for you so
calm down Debbie it's gonna be okay so
guys thanks so much for watching be sure
to give me that thumbs up if you like
what you saw subscribe to the channel
and leave me a comment below so I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen